the nhl releasing its schedule for the
upcoming season this afternoon ron
futrell joining us live
with the details this is pretty exciting
news ron oh it is we're getting down to
game time almost here david
now the most interesting part of the
schedule is that teams will be playing
each other in two game mini series we'll
call it
it cuts down on the travel and just
makes everything a little safer
in this environment right now the
knights will open the season thursday
january 14th
against the anaheim ducks it'll be a
t-mold arena but no fans allowed
initially at the games we'll see what
happens
as the season goes on official workouts
don't begin until next month but the
players are all in town and gm kelly
mccrimmon
told us today that they are covered free
and
ready to get this season going the
players have been on the ice we have all
of our
players in las vegas every player is
training
so we've been able to you know i think
benefit by
players having access to ice access to
our facilities
and i expect that for our organization
at least that it's going to be
it's going to put us in a good position
going into training camp
so here's the schedule for the knights
practice begins in less than three weeks
sunday january third to be exact there's
no pre-season they'll jump straight into
that first game against anaheim
they take friday off and play anaheim
again on saturday so sort of
back-to-back with a day off in between
they're also they're going to have 56
regular season games and the final game
of the regular season for the nights
will be
saturday may 8th against the saint louis
blues now
interesting part of the schedule the
teams will all get to know each other
very well playing each other
eight times during the regular season
that could make things interesting
four teams from the west will make the
stanley cup playoffs
and those teams will play each other in
the first two rounds of the playoffs
so it'll make for an interesting nhl
season unlike any other but
i guess we we seem to be getting used to
that these days a season
unlike in the other reporting from the
newsroom ron futrell
8 sports now